peaceful
people of fighting country we are
defending ourselves
for 12 days now we never wanted this war
but
this war was brought to us we never
wanted to kill anyone
but we have to fight back
to get the enemy out from our land and
our life
we have to tolerate what
a single nation in europe
didn't have to tolerate for the last 70
years
and now it's being decided whether
anyone else can become a victim of such
an aggression i'm talking to the leaders
of the
world
and our friends
are supporting us i spoke to polish
president again
they help us
we are working together i spoke to the
british prime minister
i spoke to the head of the italian
government
i spoke to
the president of france
i got very positive signals
and this will only help
ukraine to become stronger
and our negotiations and uh talks with
our
the situation gets worse then new
sanctions need to be introduced
to bring peace
when you refuse to give money to the
terrorists
if they don't want to stick to civilized
rules
and
they can get their
benefit from the war if they want
and forget about commerce and business
we need to fight against inhumane
evil that wants to
destroy the humanity itself
spirit of ukrainian nation
and
tricked
sanctions from the world these are the
steps we need to take
they targeted
they targeted
burned residential areas
and other little towns and villages
seized
temporarily
until they get punished and they will
get punished because our armed forces
know how to fight back
this enemy is demoralized by
what they've found
just regular cars are being destroyed
and missiles strike
just regular people
in our country
not somewhere else in our country that's
why it happened
in ukraine we always wanted peace how
many more deaths
needs to happen
what
need to give us support you need to give
us planes so that we get stronger to
fight
this is the assistance that needs to be
given not just to ukraine but to the
whole world to bring
victory so that humanity can win
the government is working on rebuilding
ukraine after we win
we have created a
special
all the territory where the military
actions are being carried out
and that will stay
for another year after the boy is
finished
and enterprises and businesses who can't
pay taxes
will get a postponement to do so
we will provide government support to
our
businesses and we will work out a system
to
rebuild ukraine quickly
and
to help people
so that we can all come back to peace to
our normal regular jobs
when we get our
country back
i'm grateful to all the owners and heads
of enterprises and businesses who carry
on doing their work
and
fulfill their obligations uh towards
their employees by paying their salaries
because in this way you are protecting
ukraine
the government
the state
fulfills all its commitments and
obligations
all
pensions are being paid out
to people
there are many people in ukraine
millions millions of people who are
capable of fighting for our country our
freedom for our national flag
yellow and blue
not three-colored flag because this is
our perspective
this is how we view our life
this is our flag
that
we
were flying in space
that we were flying
as
well italy turkey
many other countries
we never did one thing
yellow and blue
flag we never killed anyone
people peaceful people
ukraine and terror
these are completely different notions